ohne video okay leute ich jetzt hier
doch jetzt nochmal meine situation ist
folgendermaßen ich musste gestern abend
in mitternacht eine hausarbeit abgeben
eine gruppen haus arbeitet waren am ende
135 seiten und wer aus der gruppe hatte
den auftrag am ende noch alles zu
korrigieren und dann abzuschicken genau
das war ich das gestern bis mitternacht
noch an der uni ab dieser autor
geschrieben
danach bin ich natürlich einen lauf
gegangen so heute mal wieder
ausgeschlafen ersten mal seit zwei
wochen ungefähr und dann den ganzen tag
in der bude vergammelt nicht gemacht und
dementsprechend auch das video für heute
so wie sie vor mir hergeschoben ist das
gerade eben da wäre ich mich die frage
was zur hölle legte heute hoch ich habe
mich gefragt martin roos keine lust habe
ich gefallen neue folge von die ersten
videos braucht sie auch nicht von doch
kein platz fanny trends zu bleiben was
ist das anderes da ist befand hat
deswegen sagt sich da hier auf diesem
stuhl verzweifelt was soll ich machen
und dann kam die erleuchtung die
glorreiche erläuft vom himmel runter
geschickt danke gott
das einzige was wir heute machen können
in dieser live vergammelten und so ein
bisschen ersten stimmung ist dumme
kommentare lesen wir sind wieder in der
verbotenen ecke von youtube wir sind
wieder in der ecke von youtube von den
youtube kanal die ich geblockt haben die
kommentare in green werden stammen alle
aus dieser dunklen ecke
essen alles kommentare die hände
geblockt wurden entweder bei den spielen
oder einfach nur blöde kommentare es ist
wirklich das einzige videos schritte
machen kein arbeiten genau das richtige
amg music kommentiert mein video von
gestern so gut kenne ich mich mit lies
gratis kehrt wie könnt ihr auch bekommen
kriegen die leute geld dafür dass das
schreiben
es ist offensichtlichen betrug leute ich
mag trotzdem nochmal klickt nicht auf
diesen link post die 158 komischerweise
mit dem kommentar auch in der verbotenen
faction gelandet warum aber er fragt was
bringt produktplatzierung eigentlich
unter dem baby video of money but steve
produktplatzierung bringt geld okay das
kleiner funke instrument haben alles
klar
die die tv schreibt cooles video ein
interessantes thema wie immer ist er
einer meiner lieblings youtuber soweit
alles gute auch wenn er schreibt
interessante thema thema passen diktatur
jedoch kein thema geredet so oft warum
könnte das eventuell sein dass sechs
mental nicht so das paket liegt am
zweiten teil dieses kommentar ich habe
auf meinem kanal ein gewinnspiel am
laufen dicker weg du mich hoch nehmen
hat diese kommentare man freut sich so
als youtuber darüber dass man die
positive feedback kriegt und das zeugt
die leute unterhält die man streifen die
gefällt seinen kanal
ich denke eher geil danke und dann kommt
einfach sowas und man denkt sich das
doch nur geschrieben damit alle leute
die den youtuber wirklich mögen deine
scheiße hoch licon und damit ein
dreckiger kanal aufmerksamkeit bekommt
frau plötzlich okay heute wichtige rage
ich hoffe das passiert also eine regie
bitte zensieren aber es ist wirklich
berichte kommentare nerven einfach nur
und wird das führen dass ich als
nächstes kanal in den kommentaren
blockieren muss das wort kanal
blockieren bei leute immer schreiben
geht auf meinen kanal vermag auch sgl
und dann mehr anzeigen höre ich mache
auch videos wo ich mir bierflaschen anal
und in den mund stecken main kanal ok
wir uns alle wieder wissen beruhigt es
geht weiter im text denn als nächstes
schreibt cavaco eigentlich total nett du
bist auch viel besser als gewählter mehr
an
nicht blöd kurator und steht direkt
weiter alter schwede ich dachte das
video wird gut für mit was dieses video
machen wird am ende ist einfach mir übel
für die schlecht krankheiten geben
allein vom anschauen dieser kommentare
denn es geht direkt weiter bitte gebt
mir kraft geht mir stärker als die wir
durchstehen salami brötchen hd schreibt
ein setup ist so nahe druckt euch mal
den vergleich und ein eingang diese
kommentare ist es immer das gleiche
teil 1 nicht irgendeinen bezug zu dem
video unter dem der kommentar stehen und
teil 2 blieb über den ersten teil aber
immer keck main kanal früher war es so
hey leute ich war auch videochat main
kanal habt dann warst du eher leute ihr
müsst nicht anstecken aber jetzt meinen
kanal der kugel mal reinschalten heute
ist es haye live wie auch edgar veith
schaut main kanal an
nein ob acer nachricht an alle leute die
sowas machen und hier gerade zu schauen
ich gebe euch jetzt mal die antwort der
youtube community die antwort der welt
auf die frage ob leute deswegen euren
kanal anschauen achtung nein es sogar
ich kann euch durch die dampfer platten
dafür sei jetzt nicht so ein mega
positive stimmung hier auf myvideo
gekommen denn heute werden es wichtig
erst versucht in diesem video
ich hoffe ich komme von 1000 abonnenten
ohne video allein dieser name oder
schreibt experiment ich möchte wissen ob
man es schaffen kann ohne video tausend
abonnenten bekommen welche 1000 gekappt
habe werde ich ein video machen wo ich
alle abonnenten ein video vergessen dass
hier vielleicht abonnenten dazu gewinnen
könnte wäre cool benimmt das ja das habe
ich mir im letzten semester gekauft
international financial reporting
standard das ist rechnungslegung
international auf englisch und ich
dachte mir ich würde nach der klausur
letzten semester dieses buch nie wieder
brauchen aber ich brauche heute für was
fragt ihr euch
1000 abonnenten ohne video fragen bitte
hör auf deutschen wissen was ich habe
eine mega boxen serie zu machen wir
könnten hier wäre wirklich habe ich mir
gerade gedacht einfach bitte hör auf
nashtec bh wenn er bock drauf habe dass
ich so eine serie daraus machen wir
diese geblockten kommentare durch
gewesen anstatt erst mal bitte hör auf
oder hashtag bh in die kommentare
ohne video feiert würde mich freuen es
ist schon wieder der gleiche kommentar
verpiss dich okay leute das war's vom
heutigen video wenn ihr noch eine anders
sagen wenn ich daraus ein format machen
soll
mit dem titel bitte hör auf hashtag bh
schreibt dort genauso in die kommentare
bis zum nächsten mal
wladimir putin ansonsten gilt wie immer
leute die alte faustformel daumen nach
oben
zeitgleich und tschüss